this is uh richard cooper his name is i
don't know if you know how he's
entrepreneurs and cars his youtube
channel entrepreneur does a lot of
commentary like this this is one
particular video that struck me
been told to go and chase the degree
they don't need no man go and go and
work and then they hear all these songs
about being a hashtag boss girl and
batch and all that kind of stuff and
these chicks are like you know they
think that they're the bomb their
30s 40s whatever they work out they do
yoga pilates exactly like you know you
describe right
but do they know how to cook do they
know how to like please a guy do they
know how to be pleasant and agreeable
yes okay so you see how this
now from the other side got like to me
this is
this video
is what that other woman
is responding to
she's seeing this and saying i'm not
that i'm a woman i'm i can do more than
those things so you've got the worst
on the on the left and by left let's put
the men over here the worst over here
and then you've got
oh you said this to me i'm going to get
defensive now oh you said this oh i'm
going to get defensive now okay good
luck in the dating world if you're just
playing a defense game the whole time it
doesn't work like that no one wins
so this rubbed me the wrong way now he
he started off i think again
you start off where you've got people
listening right this boss girl what does
that even mean right that's the i don't
need a man
that's the 2022 i don't need a man i can
do everything
i can work i can pay the bills i can get
if i want a baby i'll just go get a
sperm donor that's who he's talking
about i did my yoga today
i make six figures
i've got a cute car i go to the club
that's who he's talking about that's a
problem right because
there's something if you've got that
much of an attitude about not needing a
man there's something going on
why
did you get burned i'm sorry to say did
you
what is going on
exactly
but he comes in and then says
do they know how to cook
traditional female role that women hate
that they hate being put in a box oh now
i'm the chef right because for someone
for a very long time what did women do
they weren't in the workforce they were
cooking they were cleaning they were at
home there was a rebellion against that
because women didn't it's not that they
hated doing all that they didn't want to
be only that
they wanted more options
and they got them
right so the last thing they want is
someone telling them to go back to the
way it was before they had those options
right
do they know how to please a man
now i think you should truthfully
yes if you're in a relationship you
should know how to make your partner
happy you should know how to make a man
happy you should know like hey maybe i
can cook on something great tonight that
he loves to eat hey adam sexually you
gotta know how to please your partner
it's it's it's the reality
but when you define it like this as if
that's the woman's role
to please a man
to cook
to be pleasant and agreeable dude get a
robot
get a housekeeper get a living
housekeeper
my job's not to be pleasant and
agreeable like sit with your hands well
i feel like i'm back in catholic school
it was like sit with your hands folded
and don't talk too loud
it's not about that
okay and and the problem is is that
what's happening now
women are multidimensional right
sometimes i'm pleasant and agreeable and
sometimes i'm not so pleasant i'm not so
i'm a human being right
women are so
tired of this structure
that used to exist they don't want that
right that now in order to say i'm not
going to be your cook i'm not going to
be pleasant now they're turning
all the way over here and saying well
i'm not going to cook at all
i'm not going to be any of those things
it's all defense
think about sports right if you're
always on defense
it's exhausting how are these people
exhausted
always trying to strategize
always trying to figure out how
somebody's gonna get one up on them
right away
always trying to figure out oh is there
she's asking me a question about my
sexual history there must be a game
being played how can i out game her game
always trying to trying to
do something that's like
i remember being on adam's show
saskatchewan he was like well why would
i get married to you know if i don't
have kids then i gotta worry she's gonna
take all my money if you're going into
the marriage worrying that somebody's
gonna take all your money you are with
the wrong girl do not marry her
you got the wrong match
if you're gonna go to every situation
like that you're you're doomed
you you cannot run a relationship like
this you will go mad you will go stark
raving mad
it's also just an unhealthy state of
mind to always assume somebody and i
understand listen i get it
there's a lot of this this is this is
blanketed chauvinism is what this is
what this guy's doing is blanketed
chauvinism it is
okay it just his tone of voice the way
he's approached there's a way to say
this stuff that's not chauvinistic he
opted not to
he could have said it a lot differently
he could have said listen do you do you
care about you know pleasing your man as
well in a relationship
do you care about you know
if he loves a great meal do you care
about being able to put that on the
table the same way that you would expect
him to put it on the table for you if
that was something you were past there's
a way to say these things that implies a
give and take he chose not to
all i'm saying to everyone out there is
if what is the goal
is the goal to just say this is a [ __ ]
storm we're in
and so you know what everybody's
shooting everybody so
let me just get out my gun and shoot
better or is the goal to just figure out
how to not be in a zone where
everybody's shooting each other to step
out and find a situation where there's
peace
talk differently remember everybody's a
person at the end of the day
there's a lot of flame throwing back and
forth it's not helping anybody
it's just not
it's not i understand let me let me just
speak to this for a second before we go
to uh
the next video which is fantastic
i get there are games i was talking to
my friend about this last night my
girlfriend
she said you know judd she said honestly
though a lot of people do play games
she is right
she is right there are a lot of people
out there especially now with the social
media the texting and they can hide
behind that and the hyper promiscuity
that's now elevated all of that there's
a lot of games being played in in dating
a lot of it
from men from women both sides a lot of
it
here's what i have to say to you there's
also a lot of people not playing those
games
find those people
find those people
don't bother with a relationship where
you have to out if you have to out
strategize someone on date one can you
imagine how tired you're going to be on
date 10
also you're not going to want to share
your
abundance i say abundance like because i
mean your home your wealth that you
accumulate your goods your child with
somebody who you think is secretly out
to get you
all the time
this is not healthy if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]